el múltiple homicidio se produce dos
días después del asesinato de un policía
en esta misma favela hay que destacar
que la corte suprema de brasil ha
prohibido toda operación policial
durante la pandemia sin previo aviso a
la procuraduría por esta razón las
organizaciones que defienden los
derechos humanos tildan esta operación
de ilegal hay que recordar también que
no es la primera masacre que se produce
este año río de janeiro en mayo en la
favela de jacarezinho 28 personas
murieron tras una operación policial que
incluso fue condenada por la onu por ser
considerada de es necesariamente
violenta y es que la policía de río de
janeiro es considerada una de las más
mortíferas de brasil sólo el año pasado
en esta ciudad murieron mil 245 personas
a manos de la policía curiosamente los
asesinatos en esta ciudad vienen bajando
en lo que va de año se ha registrado el
número más bajo de homicidios desde
1991 pero los expertos sin violencia no
son optimistas y atribuyen esta bajada
del 6% de homicidios al avance de las
milicias grupos de paramilitares que
controlan al menos el 60 por ciento del
territorio de río de janeiro
disfrutándolo al narcotráfico